white to move 10 seconds yes sir yes
again another one that I've seen but I
don't remember the solution of course
you seen them all of course A4 Bishop A3
and then I think it's Knight C5 there no
I think it's A4 H5 takes G6 takes E6
Bishop A3 yep and then white looks
totally
lost I mean on the glance I would guess
H5 GH G6 E6 then Knight
and the pawn queen and and A4 exactly
beautiful and I think it might be
G6 E6 Bishop a knight B4 Bishop B before
a stop he keep going that's it G6 take
yep E6 got him Bishop A3 is forced and
this is like the only moment that
tripped me up oh wait I can knight B4
take A4 that's it the problem is in my
mind it's like I'm trying to recall
something rather than calculate
calculate because like I know I've seen
before